primero significa que el presidente
macron no logró tener el número de
diputados suficiente para hacer pasar a
la ley de reforma de la jubilación
significa también que nos lleva una una
vía de relaciones sociales muy difíciles
y muy complejas porque manifestarmente
lo los sindicatos no van a dejar de ser
de de combatir esa ley y efectivamente
un clima social muy complicado que es
desde hoy están llevando a la falta con
provocaciones policiales también para
que el clima se degrade Y eso es algo
que preocupa mucho por ejemplo esta
mañana hubieron tres diputados de la
Francia sumisa que fueron a apoyar a la
gente que recoge la basura y la policía
cargó lo estiró lacrimógena Y esa es la
situación o sea están llevando a la
falta y por el momento todo el mundo se
se queda tranquilo para que el ejercicio
es democrático haya hasta el final En
todo caso no somos nosotros que ponemos
un freno a la democracia en el
parlamento Qué opciones Le quedan al al
pueblo francés y también a ustedes desde
el punto de vista legislativo para
contrarrestar parar revertir estas
reformas
resolver con el movimiento social
fundamentalmente que nosotros tenemos el
deber y la función de acompañar Entonces
concretamente estamos a la disposición
de los sindicatos para para acompañarlo
en la lucha que va a llegar y que
probablemente va a ser más dura que lo
que fue hasta ahora Gracias en sentido
general Cuál es su mensaje a la
población francesa
concretamente el mensaje no soy yo que
lo doy en la población que nos da a
nosotros que ellos no quieren trabajar
más tiempo por menos dinero y degradar
las condiciones de vida de la gente en
este país en Francia se crea mucha
riqueza en las cosas de repartirla
diferentemente y dejar de haber un
sistema de repartición de las riquezas
que aprovecha los más rico al costado de
los más pobres Muchas gracias Rodrigo
Arenas diputados de la Francia en sumisa
con declaraciones exclusivas para
[Música]